the story of A Game's journey into
legendary status and you too can become
legendary in the new fantasy strategy
game from the creators of Rise of
Kingdom's call of dragons nailed it call
of dragons is a new MMO fantasy Conquest
game that allows you to explore recruit
battle and live a fantasy world of
possibilities the likes of which we
fantasy fans dream of a world of
distinct factions spring wardens elves
humans Orcs everything you need to get
your Middle Earth Vibe on though it's
not Middle Earth it is a different world
but still getting your fantasy world on
and those are just the playable ones on
top of that you have a myriad of fantasy
races celestials goblins halflings
Giants and more play alongside other
players from around the world
or against them in PvP Train Your Heroes
with unique skills and abilities to turn
the tide of battle in an instant a
variety of behemoths are scattered
throughout the world defeat them in
battle bring them under your command
train them and release them in battle as
your secret weapon so download Call of
Dragons using my link below use promo
code plus Cod now or use the QR code on
screen to get yourself some special
rewards and now
[Music]
can you get a copyright claim in a
YouTube video for giving gas station
Deli quality acapella in a YouTube video
I don't think so so we move on so Tetris
is directed by John S Baird Stars Taryn
Edgerton and it's a biopic this man's
Vision Quest to bring Tetris from behind
the Iron Curtain of the USSR and bring
it to the rest of the world and make a
little bit of that which isn't the point
which isn't the point which is much
better than I thought it was gonna be
when I heard hey they want to make a
Tetris movie the point is I had already
seen the movie pixel so my mind went to
pixels I was like
aliens and building blocks or falling
and people have to oh God no it's biopic
about how Tetris went from the USSR to
the rest of the world and yes this is a
biopic which means based on a true story
which means we don't know where the
facts end and the begins or
vice versa but it is a guy going to the
USSR in the 80s during the Cold War so I
imagine there's a story to tell there
for the sake of entertainment
it's a really interesting one and a fun
one actually it's more light-hearted
than I thought it would be in fact at
first for the first 45 minutes or so in
this movie this movie was it was going
forward at a Rocket's Pace but it had
voice over a lot of locations you had to
know it actually uses a fun Sprite based
pixel presentation reminding me of Scott
Pilgrim Vs the World to let you know hey
we're going here now we're going there
now these are the people you need to
know and you see a little sprite
representations of them that was a gamer
in me it just clicked I I remembered
those people because of the Sprite
versions of them not the human versions
no I try to forget humans in my day
today but Sprites yeah I'll remember
those and what I liked about this movie
is it's it's a movie about a video game
but it's a video game let's face it all
of us have played and all of us have
been addicted to we called it being
tetrisized and the household I grew up
in right we were all tetrisized we've
all been tetrasized we all love being
tetrisized because we have the game we
play the game and we love the game to
this day it's always appreciate it where
there's a story a biopic about a certain
subject matter but you don't have to be
invested in that subject matter to be
invested in the film you don't have to
be a race car nut to enjoy Ford V
Ferrari you don't have to be a video
game Nut to enjoy Tetris the game and
the biopic because the game truly is
accessible to everybody
it's Tetris man but for the gamers out
there it is neat to see the history of
the video game and how Game Boy was
wrapped into this and they're like yeah
we're gonna pack Mario with that and
this dude's like you should pack it with
Tetris
all right let me go to Russia and that's
where this movie really starts as much
as I felt like this movie was throwing a
lot of information at me really quickly
for longer than most movies do to give
you the setup it is set up so when he
gets to Russia it's like okay that's
actually the setting of the film and
then it turns into a really fascinating
business film also spy Thriller calling
it a spy Thriller might feel hyperbolic
but it does have spy Thriller elements
in here this movie actually does kind of
an amazing job of having its tone be
enjoyable you know it starts out you're
like oh some video game references and
some history and lighthearted enjoyable
tone of how Tetris came to the masses it
doesn't necessarily lose that tone but
by the end you're watching some really
intense nail-biting Cold War KGB I
felt like I was watching the arms race
of video games like when I was watching
this movie I felt like the most
important and intense to come out
of the Cold War was playing out right in
front of me yeah you know Cuban Missile
that's no Tetris what can I say I'm a
sucker for balance of tone and I didn't
feel the light-hearted enjoyable tone
compromised the intense I never
felt like I had slipped into another
movie you know how that happens where a
movie has one tone and then it goes into
another tone or maybe it throws out
comedic tone you're like all right
people are clocking onto different
movies while they're filming this and
it's weird it all worked in one movie
and it always felt like the same movie
but you really feel those elements of
spy Thriller that isolation where he's
like all right I'm in Russia doing
business like great you could probably
call home in about a week in a country
that hates your guts you are Public
Enemy Number One but yeah I'm sure that
game is great and I always love it when
a movie pulls this off where I mean
Tetris was packed with the Game Boy so
obviously there is an element of well
that happens so how do you keep the
audience on their toes when essentially
they know how the story ended up and now
we do have Tetris out there have for
decades but I was still biting my ass
sales props to that but to its Gore it
is an Underdog Story you know you have
this one guy who so wants to make this
deal happen but he's he's him and he's
going up against large billionaire
douchebag corporations and the KGB the
Russian government and there's this one
good-hearted guy in there who was
literally bet the house his house that
he can get this job done all in
celebration of one of the greatest video
games of all time I also love that this
movie has a reverence and a praise to
the game Tetris and the music in this
movie was incredible too the theme we
know is the Tetris theme you know the
one
yeah that one which I guess is a Russian
tune or a Russian poem that predates the
game Tetris I just noticed the Tetris
theme though so I'm gonna call it that
that's the theme of the movie and like
any theme in a movie there are different
variations of it sometimes you get an
intense drum beat that goes along with
it sometimes it's mixed with 80s music
on top of it that amazing amazingly
works like it did in the trailer I will
say as much as I enjoyed the video game
graphics and the pixelization when they
were traveling somewhere like Fast
traveling somewhere Indiana Jones style
but there was a pretty great car chase
sequence in this movie again biting my
nails during it but then they did the
pixelization that made the movie look
pixelized like we were in a video game
and then it switched to overhead view
but actual like Game Boy video game
Graphics I never needed that for the car
chase the car chase was pretty amazing
by itself it actually took me out of it
when it started looking like a video
game it was one of the situations where
less would have been more for that but
in the end I had a great time with
Tetris it's on Apple TV right now yeah I
got Apple TV just to watch this because
it's like this I enjoy me at the biopic
I love me some Tetris and I like me a
good trailer this seemed to have all
three it did have all three no regrets
though I'm still on the free trial of
Apple TV
might cancel that now I'm a cheap
bastard zoomy which is why it's no small
thing when I say Tetris is worth
watching and worth buying on Blu-ray all
right so Tetris the biopic of how we got
it it's on Apple TV right now have you
seen it what did you think about it
whatever you thought comment below let
me know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]
foreign